you must prepare lissa for a new role as  the head of the dragomere family and  rose she'll do her duty  is this something that you want there  are a parade of people dying to be on  the throne  the only thing separating this dominion  from that fate is me  [Music]  then go out there and show them all what  you've got and if i've got nothing then  i will get you out i promise you that  guardians are raised to be tough  no matter how good you are there's good  enough and there's gone  i want to protect my best friend from  danger  good  you staying out of trouble oh you know  me i'm always dancing alongside of it  there's  something  strange happening  we will survive because there is no  other option  you